bonsoir je m'appelle doris
j'ai 41 ans
je suis un ancien sportif de haut niveau
ensuite je me suis reconverti en grande
distribution il ya 15 ans et j'ai un
rêve depuis quelques années qui est de
traverser l'atlantique en kitesurf
donc aujourd'hui je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi on passe de la grande
distribution une traversée de
l'atlantique il ya 15 ans donc je me
suis installé sur la route de ma vie
excusez moi il ya quinze ans je me suis
installé sur la route de la vie qui vous
voyait tracé assez confortable on voit
où on va on peut avancer à toute vitesse
sans trop réfléchir on est dans le
confort et tout d'un coup en 2012 je
meurs un obstacle je me fais un burn out
comme il faut bien fatigué je perds tous
mes repères un matin je me réveille je
savais plus où j'en étais bon je me suis
rangé sur sur la route ma vie sur le bas
côté
je me suis dit bon ce n'est pas normal
par contre je me suis pas posé la bonne
question je me suis dit allez doris 1
reprend ses habitudes
retour sur la route que tu connais si
bien c'est ce que j'ai fait j'avançais
m'était familière j'avançais à toute
vitesse j'aurais accéléré j'étais
impatiente je ne faisais pas trop de
pose et qui devait arriver arriva je
tombe dans le fossé que j'ai pas vu
venir
donc deux ans après je tombe enceinte
labrosse s arrête brusquement et je me
retrouvais dans une situation moins
difficile à vivre
là je me disais nourrissent pourquoi toi
mais bon je m'attardais pas trop je me
suis dit va falloir reprendre ses
habitudes vite et vous savez au sein de
soi même on a on a trois personnages on
a on à la raison on a le coeur et on a
le corps et ses trois personnages
prennent les décisions un petit peu à
votre place et là la raison me dit
medori se reprend la route était fatigué
tu la connais avance ce que je faisais
mais la raison elle était un petit peu
fatiguée un petit peu à manger parce que
c'est pris deux coups un peu difficile
donc et a laissé place au coeur et le
coeur m'a dit doris pourquoi tu ne fais
pas quelque chose qui te fait plaisir et
qu'est ce que tu veux vraiment et là je
me suis mis à réfléchir je me suis dit
aduriz ça serait bien que tu traverser
l'atlantique en kitesurf
vraiment la raison finalement elle a
vite récupéré dont je me suis retrouvé
sur cette route
vous la connaissez moi aussi ceci bien
c'est simple assez facile en ont les
dents sans dans sa zone de confort en
avance tranquillement sans trop
réfléchir
et puis un jour je me retrouve dans le
bureau avec mon patron et je comprends
que je n'avais nullement ma place au
poste que j'ai occupé ni dans
l'entreprise ni dans les secteurs
d'activité dans lequel j'ai évolué et là
devant moi c'est dresser un mur et là je
ne pouvais plus avancer
donc il fallait que je prenne une
décision il fallait que j'aille à gauche
à droite parce que je pouvais pas
revenir en arrière
fallait donc que je trouve quelle
direction prendre et ouais je ne savais
pas où aller
je ne savais pas où aller
parce que je savais pas ce que je
voulais faire ah je ne savais pas ce que
je voulais faire le coeur il n'avait pas
planter une petite graine dans ma tête
une petite idée que j'ai pas fait
grandir parce que la raison et m'a
bourré de bresse dans ta zone de confort
briest vous voulez pas traverser
l'atlantique en kitesurf
et si c'était ça c'était ça la la la
direction à prendre
j'ai donc changé de route et au toit
damman étonnamment mais je sentais pas
de joie de légèreté et
et de facilité vous allez comprendre
pourquoi
parce que la route que mon coeur a
choisi pour moi c'était celle ci et là
c'était fini avec le confort avec la
facilité avec l'habitude
là il fallait évaluer chaque pas et
chaque pas et est précaire je savais pas
vers où cette route m'a mené par contre
au mois d'octobre de l'année dernière et
mamie à travers dans l'élite et rannée
excusez-moi j'ai donc traverser la
méditerranée en kitesurf en octobre
dernier avec un départ de france port
camargue pour arriver huit jours après
en tunisie donc c'était en ligne droite
850 km il ya bateau qui m'a accompagné
et sur ce bateau j'ai pu me reposer
il ya eu des difficultés bien évidemment
celle aventure c'est c'est une
exploration c'est on va vers l'inconnu
personne ne l'a jamais fait auparavant
donc quand je suis parti j'ai eu très
peu de vent j'ai eu très très peur de ne
pas pouvoir partir et les premières
kilomètres j'ai les effets en ajoutera
que je n'arrivais même pas à monter sur
ma planche ensuite il ya eu donc la peur
de l'inconnu et vous vous le voyez bien
sur mon visage
ce visage j'ai eu presque sur toute la
traversée j'ai eu sacrément nous peur
quand même
j'ai eu peur pas de réussir au poids
j'avais peur de l'inconnu une forte
concentration et mon taux d'adrénaline
il était tellement élevé que j'avais pas
besoin de prendre du café ou du thé thé
pendant pendant toute la traversée
sur les situations de très peu devant on
a retrouvé beaucoup de vent donc au
départ on a mis entre 7 et 10 noeuds
puis ensuite c'est monté entre 30 et 59
donc à ce que vous voyez là c'était un
jour où une ligne casse avec 40 noeuds
de vent avec trente 30 mètres tant que
trois mètres de vagues
donc on va récupérer dans le petit
bateau que vous voyez là et ensuite il
ya eu des moments de magique
bien évidemment sur une traversée comme
ça naviguer en plein milieu de la
méditerranée sans voix sans voir la
terre c'est juste c'est juste
extraordinaire
ensuite il ya cette situation ensuite le
travail des équipes bien évidemment je
peux faire traverser la méditerranée
tout seul il ya tout un travail l'équipe
derrière et ils se sont arrachés tous
les jours pour me mettre à l'eau pour me
récupérer
et pour me faire traverser cette
méditerranée et le dépassement de soi
parce que là c'était le dernier jour le
jour de l'arrivée et au début c'était la
peur de ne pas pouvoir partir là c'était
de la peur de ne pas arriver puis
ensuite voir la terre être dans la baie
de bizerte
l'arrivée était proche puis l'arrivée
dans le dans le port avec l'accueil
extraordinaire des tunisiens et hull
école de voile qui m'ont accueilli et
les bizertins qui était sur le quai là
c'était la joie et le bonheur est arrivé
maintenant
pourquoi j'ai dû attendre de me prendre
ce mur avant de me lancer
on pourrait se dire bon l'idée je les ai
eus avant c'est étrange qu'il faut se
prendre un coup de marteau sur la tête
pour ce avant de se lancer
eh bien c'était la peur c'était la peur
de sortir de quelque chose qui était
familier qui était connue sortir de sa
zone de confort pour rentrer dans une
zone qu'on pourrait définir des zones de
panique parce qu'on n'a pas de repère à
mon père il était ingénieur ma mère
était médecin des deux frères ingénieur
à la maison les repères s'était pas
l'aventuré l'exploit a traversée de
l'atlantique
on va vers l'inconnu je n'avais pas de
repères
par contre une fois quand on se lance en
sort de sa zone de confort on décide de
ce qu'on veut vraiment faire on agit
avec du plaisir avec ce qu'on sait
vraiment faire avec ses talents avec
avec ses envies avec avec sa
personnalité
cette zone 2 de panique elle se
transforme en zone magique
merci
[Applaudissements]